[Musik]
wir kommen bei der sternstunde religion
noch vor wenigen jahrzehnten führte eine
sich anbahnende ehe zwischen einem
katholiken und einer protestantin
hierzulande gestellten zu einer
familienkrise heute sind interreligiöse
partnerschaften zwischen muslimen
christen hindus juden podest innen gang
und gäbe worüber sie streiten was sie
stark macht und wie ihre kinder mit der
situation leben darüber spreche ich in
dieser stunde mit stefan huber er ist
theologe und religionssoziologe dann ist
bei uns mal einer produkts allerdings
ist lebt seit 15 jahren in einer
christlich muslimischen ehe und bei uns
am tisch ist auch von atv sie ist
fachärztin für kinder- und sicherlich
herzlich willkommen in allen hier herr
huber sie forschen seit vier jahren im
bereich interreligiöse partnerschaften
in der schweiz sie sind an einer studie
die ist noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen
und sind jetzt hier noch keine
definitiven ergebnisse da und dennoch
gibt es wichtige befunde die wir uns
jetzt schon mitteilen können was sind
denn die drei wichtigsten erkenntnisse
ja so in unserer befragung zeichnet sich
ganz klar ab das interreligiöse paare im
prinzip genauso religiös sind wie die
paare wo beide partner der gleichen
religion angehören
zweitens zeigt sich dass sie
interreligiöse paare nicht mehr
konflikte berichten als mono religiöse
paare also sozusagen der der haupt ein
flug ist das interreligiöse paare ganz
normale paare sind erst einmal die halt
dieses besondere merkmal haben das ja
aus zwei verschiedenen religiösen
kulturen kommen aber wie schon gesagt
mit zugriff religiosität und flickte
scheint es keinen unterschied zu geben
und man könnte meinen ganz normale paare
alles in butter es gibt keine
spezifischen schwierigkeiten und
trotzdem mal einer produkte die sie
haben sich nachdem sie nur vier jahre
verheiratet waren dazu entschieden ein
buch über ihre christlich islamische ehe
zu schreiben
das käme ja jemanden
wahrscheinlich nicht in den sinn der
eine partnerschaft zwischen christen
christen oder zwischen gleichen
religionszugehörigkeiten hätte was hat
sie denn dazu gebracht
ich denke es waren verschiedene gründe
ich wollte mal einen anderen blick
winter zeigen auf so eine partnerschaft
und weil wir wissen es gibt sehr viele
publikationen über sehr schwierige
konstellationen aus christlich
muslimischen paaren aber vielleicht
weniger die die vielleicht auch
versuchen ein bisschen herauszufinden
was sind denn die schwierigkeiten liegen
die dann tatsächlich in der religion
oder liegen die vielleicht in anderen
bereichen und auch ein herantasten an
die kultur des anderen für uns war es
sehr wichtig unsere kultur gegenseitig
kennenzulernen und das auch ohne
irgendwelche vorbehalte sondern uns
wirklich damit auseinanderzusetzen zu
verstehen wie sind diese zwei
kulturkreise unterschiedlich warum sind
sie unterschiedlich aber auch die
differenzierung zu sehen was ist
tatsächlich religion was das kultur und
was ist tradition und wie wird das oft
vermischt und vermengt
sie sind sie sind sehr nüchtern
eigentlich an die fragestellungen auch
herangegangen haben auch kritische
überlegungen gemacht zehn jahre später
das buch erschien 2011 wie blicken sie
jetzt zurück hat sich ihre sicht
bewahrheitet oder hat sich da was
verändert ich denke ich bin nach wie vor
einverstanden mit mit einigen punkten
die ich ein buch hervor zeichne also zb
meiner meinung nach einer der
wichtigsten grundlagen damit so eine
beziehung funktioniert ist eine
gemeinsame sprache und das hört sich
jetzt vielleicht banal an aber das ist
es nicht
und das ist jetzt egal ob die paare
unterschiedliche religionen haben aber
wenn sie grundsätzlich aus zwei
unterschiedlichen ländern kommen ist die
gemeinsame sprache oftmals nicht ganz
einfach
und wir hatten das große glück dass wir
englisch als dritte sprache hatten auf
der wir bis heute alle schwierigen
gespräche führen
also wir führen die die die schwierigen
gespräche niemand
uns in der muttersprache des einen oder
des anderen partners und das hat sich
sehr bewährt was sich nicht bewährt hat
ist meine damals etwas euphorischer
sichtweise auf den arabischen frühling
da
da sind wir natürlich heutzutage sehr
ernüchtert also was da die einflüsse
sind auch was in den herkunftsländern
der jeweiligen partner und partnerinnen
die aus einem anderen land kommen da
hinein spielen das werden wir sicher
noch diskutieren frau sev sie arbeiten
im bereich mit kindern und jugendlichen
und wer zu ihnen kommt der steckt
meistens in einer konfliktsituation und
sie haben auch patienten patientinnen
und deren eltern die in diesen wie
religiösen konstellationen sind was
erleben sie denn da also ich erlebe im
alltag beides einmal ein gelingendes das
hängt von den eltern ab und ein mal eben
mehr konfliktreiche und spannend finde
ich eben dass das religiöse vielmehr mit
wert für mit und zu tun hat also zb ein
islamisches vater und eine christliche
mutter sie lebten zusammen in suhl also
im sudan
da hat das ganz gut funktioniert weil
sozusagen die mutter also die
schweizerin sozusagen alles angenommen
hat was ihn zu dem brauch war sei es die
feiertage sei es schwangerschaft geburt
also wie das im islam gelebt wird und
jetzt sind sie aber hier und jetzt eben
andere an ein anderer brauch und hier
entwickelt das kind eben andere
herausforderungen weil in den schulen
sind die feiertage anders als wir also
wie es im zugang gewohnt war also im
moment sei zwar schwierig und andere
sozusagen herausforderungen weil
sozusagen die gesellschaft anders damit
umgeht auch die frau hat hier andere
werte als wo sie in den sudan war da hat
sie dass al soofi das akzeptiert zb
kopftuch tragen also moschee besuchen
und hier möchte sie aber etwas anderes
und damit entstanden bestimmt
ja wert unterschiede wo dann die kinder
mitbekommen
also es hängt sehr viel von den eltern
ab was sie den kindern vermitteln ist es
eben nicht nur religion was meine sich
sondern sich die kultur es ist tradition
und auch die nachbarschaft also die
gesellschaft in der wir leben alles hat
einfluss und sie die herausforderungen
über wer also überwinden oder auch nicht
scheinen die frage der kinder und die
aus interreligiösen partnerschaften
hervorgehen ist das eine besondere
herausforderung also werden leicht
religiöse unterschiede stark auf die
kinder projiziert oder werden sie sagen
da gibt es vielleicht tatsächlich
unterschiede im vergleich zu kulturell
einheitlichen familien jetzt also das
sehe ich eben unterschiede wenn man
kinder hat als wir man keine kinder hat
weil die kinder müssen das hier aus
baden oder die müssen das ausleben in
dieser gesellschaft das fängt schon mit
der namensgebung an also wenn der junge
mohammed heißt reagieren die
fachpersonen schon anders also mohammed
impliziert schon muslimisch sein also
fachperson meinen sie was schule bei
schule behörden also in dieser
gesellschaft in der wir hier leben enter
into dann wäre das ganz normal die
meisten heißen amira oder mohammed oder
anders aber hier in der schweiz fällt
man schon durch den namen auf ja schon
am telefon um die dass man fremdländisch
wahrgenommen hat und dann gibt es viele
implikationen praktisch der name ist
anders welche religion welche braucht
also so hat es eben einen großen
einfluss auf die kinder wie kann man die
kinder dahingehend stärken
identitätsbildung in der entwicklung
unterstützen also das ist dann sozusagen
ein part wo erwachsene übernehmen können
verrückt sie haben entgegen ihrem wunsch
keine kinder aber sie thematisieren es
im buch und sie haben sich dabei auch
überlegungen gemacht jetzt diese frage
die natürlich immer kommt wie hätten sie
ihre gemeinsamen kinder denn erzogen
welche religion
wir haben uns sehr viele gedanken dazu
gemacht doch viel darüber gesprochen und
das
waren oftmals auch schwierige gespräche
ich muss dazu sagen mein mann hat einen
sohn aus erster ehe
und da kann ich sehr stark unterstützen
was sie gerade gesagt haben also das
kind wird natürlich wahrgenommen über
den namen in einer ersten linie kommt
darin eine schublade rein was nicht
einfach ist gerade in einer welt die
vielleicht dem islam gegenüber sehr
kritisch ist das haben wir erlebt mit
meinem stiefsohn das hat sehr sehr viel
probleme hervorgebracht das war nicht
einfach für ihn
und da war es unsere aufgabe auch
aufzuzeigen die ganzen positiven zeiten
des islams die positiven seiten dieser
gesellschaft und weg zu gehen von dieser
reine negativen beleuchtung aber auf
deine frage zurück auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen
wir haben uns ganz klar dazu
entschlossen dass wir die kinder so
erziehen werden oder aufwachsen lassen
was für die kinder der auch der einfache
weg ist ihre eigenen identitätsfindung
und wir haben dort aber einen klaren
unterschied gemacht wenn wir in einem
islamischen land gelebt hätten was
durchaus eine möglichkeit gewesen wäre
dann wären die kinder muslimische
gewesen was ja auch in einem islamischen
land üblich ist dass es die religion des
vaters ist hier in der schweiz haben wir
uns dazu entschieden und das war kein
einfacher entscheiden
er hat viele gespräche gebraucht dass
das kind nicht getauft würde aber dass
das kind auch nicht islamisch erzogen
würde beide religionen kennen lernen
würde und sich dann später selber
entscheiden könnte ich kann nicht sagen
ob das funktioniert hätte mal
ausprobieren konnten wir es nicht wir
kennen allerdings paare die das so
gelebt haben und wo sich dann die
geschwister zum teil auch
unterschiedlich entschieden haben und
ich denke es ist wichtig weil für mich
war klar dass ich nicht zum islam
konvertieren würde was für viele paare
eine möglichkeit ist die tun dieses
problem umgehen oder oder finden dort
eine lösungen sagen da eine partner
passt sich religiös dem anderen
so mannschaft quasi künstlich diese
homogenität da und wenn das passt dann
ist das sicher auch eine möglichen haid
ich denke jede beziehung ist anders
jedes ach ist ja super sie haben in
ihrer frage in ihrer online befragung
zum studie bei der kann man übrigens
immer noch mitmachen
diese als klammer bemerkung blenden den
link gerade ein und sie freuen sich
glaube ich bin ich noch ganz viele tage
und auch einige leute melden und zwar
auch solche die notabene nicht in einer
interreligiösen partnerschaft sondern
auch in einer religiös homogenen
partnerschaft leben
sie haben in ihrer online befragung auch
natürlich die kinder frage gestellt was
ist dabei herausgekommen
ja das sind sehr interessante befunde
aber zunächst noch mal ich möchte allen
paaren danken die an der befragung
teilgenommen haben und möchte wirklich
alle interessierten bieten oder ein
laden dazu an der befragung weiter
teilzunehmen
ja wir haben gefunden dass etwa 20
prozent der interreligiösen eltern auch
sagen ihre kinder interreligiös wenn sie
kinder haben sie auch interreligiös
erzogen haben
aber diejenigen die noch keine kinder
hatten dass es ungefähr ist das sind 60
prozent von denen wir befragt haben
und dort haben sie gesagt haben wir
gefragt wie würden sie denn ihre kinder
erziehen und dort haben 69 prozent
gesagt wir erziehen sie interviews das
heißt wenn nicht sozusagen an die er
angehen
dann hab ich schon da sehe ich positiv
dann habe ich einen wunsch auch etwas
interreligiöses weiterzugeben
aber wenn es dann sozusagen realität
wird ja und gerade wenn ein kind kommt
dann stellt sich eben die gretchenfrage
wie halte ich es mit der religion nicht
nur mit der religiosität und das ist
natürlich jetzt nehmen wir zum beispiel
ein muslimischer christliches paar ja
wenn jetzt ein jugend kommt stets so
lief sofort die frage weiter beschnitten
bei mädchen ist das erst mal kein thema
er da kann man sozusagen viel einfacher
das warten lassen also eben wenn man so
bald wirklich kinder da sind dann gibt
es noch mal eine neue qualität
auseinandersetzung von ihnen würde ich
gerne auch wissen funktioniert das
eigentlich wenn man bevor die kinder
abmachungen trifft also sozusagen eine
abmachung in der theorie unter der
hypothese und wenn dann die realität
eintrifft diese möglicherweise doch
alles anders genau ist sicher
individuell ich kann nicht eine
verallgemeinerung treffend aus meiner
erfahrung aber spannend finde ich dass
es aus meiner sicht in der praxis von
früher beginnt die frage beim jungen
richtig also die beschneidung ist thema
aber was ich von den eltern höhere ist
ja ein der transkulturellen arbeitet
dass man schon vor der schwangerschaft
dieser frage stellt weil eine
schwangerschaft im islam anders gelebt
wird als im christentum zum beispiel zb
ich höre einfach von den schwangeren als
mieter oder die die junge frauen die
schwanger werden wollen wie
enthaltsamkeit also enthaltsamkeit in
der schwangerschaft wie geht man um mit
dem waschen des säuglings wie geht man
überhaupt um mit nach der geburt also
auch die geburt hat unterschiedliche
vorgehensweise also in der
schwangerschaft gibt es andere ideen als
im christentum also bei den muslimen
also und deswegen ist schon viel also
fragen also viele fragen die
herausforderungen denen die jungen
frauen ausgesetzt sind aber auch viele
gesetze so von der scharia höre ich von
den frauen weil was darf ich dann was
darf ich nicht wie kleide ich mich dann
also das sind schon fragen die sie als
sehr herausfordernd erleben vor allem
hat sie keinen über mit dem sie das
besprechen können also die möchten dann
ihre eigene familie nicht belasten und
die versuchen das in der ehe alleine zu
lösen also bei inter kulturellen paaren
aber das sind wieder fragen die
aufkommen
das ist beginnt aus meiner sicht schon
wie früher dann denken sie waren erleben
dann die kinder die aus diesen
partnerschaften hervorgehen wann und
unter welchen umständen erleben die das
als eine qualität dass sie in zwei
unterschiedlichen systemen religion und
kultur aufwachsen und unter welchen
umständen wird es zum problem also eine
ressource als ressource erleben die
kinder wenn beide eltern sozusagen
gemeint
an einem strang ziehen also wie sie sich
nicht irritieren lassen zum beispiel von
den feiertagen muslimischer feiertag ist
anders als christentum
gleichzeitig ist es auch so mit den
alten weisen fasten zum beispiel soll
ein ein kind in der schule dann auch
fasten oder so es nicht also gibt es das
toleranz in dieser gesellschaft oder
eher nicht und das sind sozusagen viele
fragen die dann aufkommen aber als
ressourcen berichten die kinder und
jugendliche wenn sie diese also
zweisprachigkeit aber auch familien
großfamilien
das ist ja bereich hand aber auch dass
das als nicht als nachteil wahrgenommen
wird in dieser gesellschaft sondern es
ist schön dass du zwei religionen in dir
hast dass das erleben sie sozusagen als
bereicherung und als negativ erleben
besonders mädchen wenn sie sich nicht
frei entfalten können also kleidung zb
kopftuch oder gar kein sport teilnahme
zum beispiel nicht schwimmen
das erleben sie in dieser gesellschaft
häufig als eben nicht dazu gehören nicht
dazu gehörig kite oder sogar ausgrenzung
das ist schwierig dann auch das den
eltern zu vermitteln
wie schätzen sie die lage ein wann kommt
es zu loyalitätskonflikten also wenn
beispielsweise der muslimische
elternteil oder auch ist ein
hinduistischer älter teil könnte es ja
auch sein vielleicht kulturell
strengeren regeln auferlegt also
vielleicht jetzt der schweiz rechten
teil der christlich oder vielleicht auch
konfessionslos sein könnte und das kind
dann sozusagen nicht einsieht warum es
mit diesen regeln belastet werden soll
also ich erlebte es vor allem wenn die
kinder in anderen ländern geboren wurden
und dann hierher kommen
das sind auch teilweise flüchtlinge da
erlebe ich eine herausforderung hohe
anspannung mit dem versuch sich zu
integrieren in der schweiz mit dem
versuch dazu gehören zu wollen die
sprache zu lernen und dann kann ein
elternteil sehr streng sein der zum
beispiel aus afghanistan kommt habe ich
gerade
ein elternteil der der möchte aber dass
die das mädchen sich eben so bekleidet
dass sie sozusagen sich schützt er
möchte gerne dass sie nicht so viel raus
geht obwohl sie jugendlicher ist und das
ist sehr belastend einerseits aber sie
ist auch loyal mit dem vater weil bisher
hat es ja auch gut funktioniert in
afghanistan das sind also fragen womit
sie in die therapie kommt und sagt ich
möchte mein vater genügen
aber ich möchte auch dazu gehören und
sie darf sogar ins gymnasium übertreten
weil sie sehr intelligent ist und dort
eher wird sie auch noch mehr infrage
gestellt also du trägst ein kopftuch bis
zu 1 unterdrückt das mädchen viele
fragen die sie dann zum sichern sieht
dann sag ich mal mit meinem vater und da
drückt mich nicht aber ich möchte auch
dazu gehören
und da hat sie wie kein ansprechpartner
und sie sagt dann hat er öfters gesagt
sie kann zum schulsozialarbeiter oder zu
soziologische dienst aber sie sagt dass
sie verstehen mich auch nicht sie
stempel mich dann sofort ab und sagen
ich habe probleme und vielleicht muss
ich raus aus meiner familie also die
französische lieder sorgen eine
vertrauensperson auch zu finden von der
sie ausgehend haben die hat verständnis
für beide situationen das ist das was
sie bräuchten menschen die zurückhaltend
sind achtsam zu hören und vorurteile
abbauen helfen sie brauchen wir ein
gesprächspartner sie selber werden das
richtige für sich dann wählen wie sie
gesagt haben dass die kinder eigentlich
ganz gut
regentief bieten könnten wir haben das
jetzt schon mehrmals hier gehört dass
diese diese fehlende dieses fehlende
beratungsangebot dass die menschen unter
umständen nicht wissen an wen sie sich
wenden können sie haben das beispiel
vorhin von von einer schwangeren frau
gebracht
herr huber was war denn eigentlich ihre
motivation diese studie zu machen ja
eine wichtige position und ein wichtiges
motiv versichert dass wir
beratungsstellen unterstützen können
also dass wir bewertung stellen die
interkulturelle und interreligiöse paare
beraten
dass wir denen material an die hand
geben können weil es ist ja auch wichtig
zwischen dem interkulturellen und
interreligiösen faktor zu unterscheiden
ja es ist nicht beides das gleiche das
eines kultur das anders religion und von
unserer seite ist das ist die grundidee
dass wir den beratungsstellen weiter
geben dass sie in bezug auf die
religiosität einmal unterscheiden
sollten zwischen der sozialen seite und
der persönlichen seite und dass sie dann
auf dieser basis dann zielgerichtet
beraten können was bedeutet soziale
religiosität und persönlicher sozialer
religiosität das können sie das hängt
mit kirche gegangen oder moschee besucht
zusammen oder auch mit der teilnahme an
sonst haben wir alle weiteren
aktivitäten einer kirchgemeinde oder
moscheegemeinde und damit ist eben
verbunden dass man in einen sozialen
körper integriert wird man gehört dem
dann zur gemeinde oder zur moschee dazu
und damit ist verbunden dass die anderen
mitglieder der maschine der gemeinde
erwartungen haben das ist die eine seite
und die zweite seite ist die personalie
das ist schlicht die frage welche
beziehung habe ich zu der spirituellen
eben ja ist das für mich
selbstverständlich dass es eine
spirituelle ebene gibt also glaube ich
an gott dann beschäftige ich mich damit
stelle ich mir fragen habe ich erfahrung
ich spüre ich dass die spirituelle ebene
da ist und versuche ich selber mit
dieser spirituellen ebene also mit gott
in verbindung zu treten sei setzt durch
gebet meditation oder pilgern oder auch
in dem wie zb alleine in den wald gehen
und ganz zu mir kommen und dann in der
stille sozusagen gott begegnen oder dem
sprit werden und unsere idee ist das ist
die dass sogar die soziale seite die
vierten öfter zu problemen weil da kommt
dann die erwartung ja du bist doch ein
guter christ oder ein guter muslim du
musst doch du musst doch so wie wir das
machen ja und auf der und auf der
anderen seite die personale seite ist
meine als nach ressource weil ihr
stärker jemand spirituell ist
kann er sich auch mit religiöser auf
einer religiösen basis von der sozialen
seite emanzipieren und sagen ja ich weiß
dass sich religiös bin ich weiß dass ich
meine beziehung zu gott habe hier
braucht man nicht vorschreiben was ich
mache rammbock sie nicht im ganz hilft
ja wir leben sie wie erleben sie den
anders nur unterschreiben weil das ist
dann wieder ein kollektiv das da
eindringt und es war auch interessant zu
sehen jetzt gerade in der beziehung von
meinem mann und mir wir sind beide
eigentlichen kollektiv gesellschaften
groß geworden er in ägypten ich im
engadin
obwohl das ja eigentlich in der schweiz
ist aber halt auch anders geprägt und
wir verstehen was das kollektiv
ausmachen kann und das kann ich nur
unterschreiben
dann kommt von außen der druck muss so
sein und du musst so sein und dem haben
wir uns zu einem großen teil wirklich
selber entzogen
und weil weil ich denke der druck ist
schon groß genug man hat druck von
familie man hat druck von gesellschaft
und so weiter
dann braucht es nicht noch so einen
selbst auferlegten druck aber das kann
ich nur unterschreiben aber das ist halt
auch nicht für jedes paar richtige weg
ich wollte sagen also ich muss da schon
noch mal kritisch nachfragen ist das
nicht auch eine sehr eurozentristisch
halt um diese spaltung zwischen einer
persönlichen spirituellen religiosität
und auf der anderen seite einer einer
kollektiv ausgerichteten auf
gemeinschaft und letztlich ist doch da
auch dieser gesellschaftliche druck da
auf jene die aus diesem kollektiv
gesellschaften kommen sich dieser
europäischen persönlichen religiosität
unterzuordnen hat genau das würde ich
wollte sie jetzt wirklich auch
unterstützen weil das ist das
individualistische also studierter
intellektuelle haben die möglichkeit
aber auch finanzielle ressourcen man
kann dann aus diesem kleinen dorf weiß
ich nicht ob gemeinde in gardinen oder
kanton dann sozusagen rausgehen man hat
eben diese möglichkeit aber nicht alle
menschen die in diesem kulturellen oder
religiösen situation leben haben diese
chance
das hängt von sehr viel ressourcen ab
die eben im europäischen kontext
bestehen aber in vielen anderen ländern
bestehen sie nicht als mann abhängig von
der familie von dr
da kann man noch so differenziert denken
aber in der umsetzung ist dann das
soziale wieder stärker und daher ist es
in der umsetzung eben nicht einfach er
habe habe ich die stimme völlig zu man
kann sich das nicht aussuchen aber ich
würde sagen es gibt so ein trend und das
ist nicht unbedingt europäische hängt
auch mit der entwicklung der wirtschaft
zusammen der politik der demokratie und
so weiter und das nennt man
säkularisierung und das heißt dass
religiöse institutionen an macht
verlieren
dass die eine seite und die zweite seite
ist dass wir in unserer gesellschaft
immer mehr selber uns definieren müssen
ja früher hat waren die rollen
vorgegeben war man man weiß weil man
mann war oder frau wusste man was man
von ihm erwartet dann wenn man einen
bestimmten beruf ergriffen hat musste
man auch die habt ihr und die rolle und
mit der religion auch heute ist es so
ich musste mich selber entscheiden 'bin
ich mann frau unter diverse ich muss
mich selber entscheiden welchen beruf
ergreife ich und welche persönlichkeit
habe ich wie wie definierte ich nicht
und das gilt eben auch für die religion
und das ist etwas was ich vermutlich
also ich vermute mal auch weltweit nicht
aufhalten lässt
also sie sehen das als eine freiheit
aber kann daraus auch eine überforderung
nein ich sehe dass ich sehe das als
erste x als einen sozialen prozess der
wahrscheinlich nicht umkehrbar ist und
aus diesem prozess kommt einerseits
freiheit ich kann mich selber definieren
aber es kommt zugleich auch
überforderung weil ich muss mich
definieren und wenn ich mich selber
definieren muss und ich definiere mich
falsch dann bin ich auch für die
konsequenzen verantwortlich
und dann vertrage ich sozusagen die
schuld wenn ich etwas in den sand
gesetzt und das ist sicher ein
überfordern
diese definition die selbstdefinition
die nimmt man ja nicht an einem
bestimmten punkt im leben einfach mal
vor und dann ist die
lebensende unumkehrbar und dann
religiosität ist doch auch etwas was
sich verändert über die lebensspanne was
haben sie für erfahrungen gemacht frau
bog mit ihrem mann hat sich seine
religiosität verändert über die zeit
also ich denke was wir beide
festgestellt haben dass mit den
herausforderungen die das leben bringt
die religiosität entweder an stärke
gewinnt oder verliert dann die soziale
oder die ausgesprochen die masse die
persönliche die persönlich also bei uns
beiden ist es ausgesprochen die
persönliche religiosität die sich sehr
stark verändert hat und und und die auch
vor vorwiegend ist und die uns auch
stärkt in herausforderungen ich meine
wir haben alle unsere herausforderungen
im leben wir müssen geliebte menschen
gehen lassen wir müssen auf vielleicht
wirtschaftlich schwierige situationen
reagieren berufliche veränderungen und
so weiter und da ist uns halt beiden die
religion eine stütze und ich denke dass
das ist auch das was wir eigentlich auch
immer versucht haben zu vermitteln auch
auch dem so meines mannes gegenüber
religion kann etwas sehr schöne sehr
tröstendes sehr hilfreicher sein
es muss nichts dogmatisches seien in
berlin ihr ein dogmatisch sondern das
kann eine sehr sehr große stütze sein
der stiefsohn ihr stiefsohn eine person
ihres ihres mannes aus erster ehe von
dem haben sie mir erzählt dass er sich
inzwischen sehr distanziert hat von von
jeglicher religion muss man sagen
wie kam das bei ihrem mann das war
anfänglich eine sehr große
herausforderung für ihn das anzunehmen
dass er hat sich selbst würde liegen
über seine familie seine ergibt sich
schon von ich denke das kann da noch
dazu dass es kommt immer dazu unter
druck der familie der ist nicht zu
unterschätzen ihnen den gesellschaften
aber für meinen mann war es auch er hat
am anfang immer das gefühl gehabt ich
habe irgendetwas falsch gemacht dass er
das nicht sieht oder da keinen keine
wurzeln schlagen konnte im islam
inzwischen
inzwischen hat er es akzeptieren können
und sieht durchaus dass wir diesem
jugend jungen menschen sehr viel
moralvorstellungen haben mitgehen können
unabhängig davon ob das christlich oder
islamische moralvorstellungen sind und
er ist ein gefestigter mensch der in
eine gute zukunft geht momentan und ich
denke auch da kann man sagen das ist die
momentaufnahme mit religion sich nicht
sich keiner religion zugehörig fühlt
aber dass auch das kann sich ändern im
laufe des lebens was mein mann einmal
gesagt hat und dieser satz hat mich sehr
geprägt er hat gesagt ich bin sehr
dankbar wächst mein sohn in einem land
auf wo er das sagen kann wo er diesen
diesen schritt machen darf was in
ägypten schwierig gewesen wäre und ich
denke das ist natürlich der der vorteil
in einer gesellschaft wie wir leben wo
so etwas möglich ist wie wäre das
herausgekommen wenn wir jetzt in ägypten
leben würden
da wäre natürlich der druck der
gesellschaft ganz ein anderer gewesen
gegenüber diesen schritt obwohl ich
meiner meinung nach sicher bin dass es
auch in islamischen ländern eine
wachsende anzahl atheisten gibt die
dürften sich aber natürlich
dementsprechend weniger vielleicht
darzustellen dass dem so ist vorausschau
sie arbeiten ganz spezialisiert auch im
bereich von migration und trauma
ich höre immer wieder von menschen mit
die migriert sind das für sie nicht
religiös explizit aber gemeinschaft die
stütze ist das wäre ein unterschied zu
dem was verbraucht jetzt gerade
thematisiert haben fällt es dann diesen
menschen erster generation also die in
der migrations situation sehen die auch
schweres eine persönliche religiosität
überhaupt zu entwickeln also diese frage
von persönliche religiosität das ist bei
vielen menschen im endspiel die gration
hintergrund gar nicht so thema für sie
ist einfach die religion das gelebte das
tradierte war schon immer so das hat mir
mein vater mein urgroßvater schon so
weit gebracht aber sie denken nicht über
diese um
verschiedene nach das ist das was ich
vorher auch sagen wollte in der praxis
gibt es immer also es gab schon immer
sicherheit so zu leben
mein kind zu taufen oder mein kind zu
beschneiden also den sohn dass das sind
so tradierte relikt also religiosität
aber wenn man mit ihnen zu diskutieren
würde es hängt natürlich auch davon
welche schulbildung sie haben welche
reflexionsfähigkeit aber ich möchte
nicht alle unter einem kamm scheren
ich beobachte dort mehr alltagsleben
alltag sicherheit gemeinschaft in diese
gesellschaft wo sie häufig nicht
dazugehörig sich wahrnehmen
da gehen sie gerne in moschee oder oder
in die kirche um einfach dort in ihre
sprache und in ihre kultur das leben zu
dürfen
es ist also anders als wenn sie zu einer
schweizerischen kirche gehen als wären
sie zu einer elektrischen oder eben eine
andere kultur zu sagen in die kirche
gehen da fühlen sie sich halt heimisch
wie sie sagen geht es vielmehr um
gemeinschaft um verstanden werden um die
gleiche sprache haben
aber auch ohne worte sozusagen gleiche
rituale zu haben und es gibt auch den
kindern häufig sicherheit weil da fühlen
sie sich gleich mit den kindern die dort
die sprache lernen in der kirche oder
bestimmte verhaltensweisen dem wunsch
nach geborgenheit sicherheit verstanden
werden stehen an der gegenteilige
erfahrungen aber auch entgegen nämlich
diskriminierungserfahrungen und erhob er
sie haben in ihrer studie auch nach
diskriminierungserfahrungen gefragt
welchen einfluss haben die denn auf die
situation von die religiösen paaren also
in der schule zeigt sich hier auch
relativ klar dass die religiöse oder
interreligiöse paare mehr
diskriminierungserfahrungen haben als
homogene religiöse paare und das stellt
natürlich für die hat eine
herausforderung dar weil sie werden also
stigmatisiert
das ist die frage also was ist denn so
anders an uns und damit wir werden sie
gezwungen sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
sie werden in eine bestimmte ecke
gestellt und das ist sozusagen eine
zusätzliche belastung mit der sie
umgehen müssen
aber wenn jetzt schon die realität die
ist ich glaube um fast die hälfte der
neu verheirateten sind die nationale
paare muss man aber sagen
dann deutet doch das darauf hin dass das
eine eine normalität ist ja sagen waren
die diskriminierung ja es sind eben
binational oder bikulturelle ist noch
nicht die religiös und das religiöse das
kann ebenso zu sagen wieso ein
kennzeichen des vision mag ja wo man
dann etwas aufhängen kann was vielleicht
oder einen konflikt auch daran
festmachen kann was gar nicht an sich
wie groß ist das ist eben einfach
sichtbar
eben das ist das beispiel ist im das
kopftuch werden das sieht man ja ab und
dann kann man da alle möglichen anderen
punkte ankleben und ein konflikt ab aber
es ist eben manchmal nicht trennbar das
ist das problem
wie schon vorher sagte bereits der name
kaum in der schweiz für das zu sein dass
jemand den namen mohammed bekommt oder
ist man also eher nicht weil das ist so
nicht dazu gehörig in dieser kultur also
wie setze ich meine beobachtung
das heißt die religion hat einfluss auch
auf die kultur auf die namensgebung und
das wiederum hat einfluss in der schweiz
wie menschen oder fachpersonen mit den
kindern umgehen also das spielt alles
eine rolle und das wiederum macht mit
dem kinder hier geboren wird also hier
in der schweiz in zürich
ich bin doch genau wie der lukas ich bin
mit ihm im kranken als meine mutter hat
mich im krankenhaus geboren seine mutter
auch es gibt solche geschichten die ich
höre und trotzdem bin ich immer anders
als er also da kann ich da eine andere
erfahrung
also wir sind 2006 aus deutschland in
die schweiz gekommen meine frau eine
stelle als pastorin angefangen hat und
dann kam unser ältester jannik haben die
schule und dann gehen die gleichen die
in ein klassenlager und dann war da mit
dem leonardo und mit dem mit einem
serbischen nahm weiter zusammen in einem
zimmer ja und also in der sekundarschule
wo jannik war da waren da war die
vielfalt so groß dass man wenn man
keinen schweizer oder keinen
christlichen namen hatten dass man
eigentlich da nicht diskriminiert wurde
hatte ich den eindruck dass doch gut
leben da hatten wir aber lebt das 40
handykauf teilweise schwierig war als
als deutscher sozusagen in diese kultur
rein zu kommen
ich möchte auch nicht sagen dass alle
diskriminiert werden das möchte ich
jetzt nicht sagen ich möchte sagen dass
dort verschiedene herausforderungen sind
die menschen die nicht diese die
andersartigkeit oder die eine andere
religion haben haben also es hat einfach
viel mehr bewegung im alltag weil auch
der name schon spielt eine rolle aber es
haben viele internationale menschen
unterschiedliche namen das ist keine
frage aber prozession mit dem islam
diskutieren kann es gerade in was ihr in
den medien in letzter zeit gehört haben
eine negative besetzung sein oder
vorurteil dass man sich vorher gefragt
haben kopftuch wenn einen ein mädchen
aus libanon sich bewirbt mit kopftuch
ich habe so eine patientin der hat
ablehnungen bekommen
verschiedene institutionen aber ohne
kopftuch hat sie eben einladung bekommen
das finde ich ist es real ist es heute
das ist sicher real also dass das würde
ich auch sagen und der blick auf den
islam ist ja grundsätzlich wenn man wenn
man sich umhört in erster linie 1 1
negativ belastet da dem man oftmals
hörte man oftmals sieht und natürlich
beeinflusst dass auch die sichtweise der
menschen dann auf eine sie haben in
ihrem buch auch erwähnt dass vorher
abgesprungen sind
also sie haben auch diese diese
kritische betrachtung dazu sogar
zurückweisen er war ja dass das erfährt
man natürlich das erfährt man dass gibt
das gehört mit dazu aber das gehört
wahrscheinlich war allem mit dazu filme
nicht ganz genau der norm entspricht was
nicht jedem passt aber das ist richtig
das sind das in schwierige
herausforderung herausforderungen was
ich auch festgestellt habe bei mir ist
wenn dann diese wenn dann diese
diskriminierungen kommen von aus und
wenn dann diese diese diese angriffe
oder diese verallgemeinerungen kommen
dann stellt man sehr sehr gut fest also
schutz von thun hat dieses bild der oder
dieses dieses diese theorie aufgestellt
vom inneren team das wir alle haben wir
sind ja keine ein artige persönlichkeit
wir haben eine innere pluralität und die
verändert sich mit solchen angriffen von
außen und das habe ich bei mir selber ja
auch er festgestellt man geht dann in
die defensive man geht dann in eine man
versucht dann sich selber und sein
partner zu schützen und dann übernehmen
andere teile der inneren pluralität die
die macht und das ist sicher auch bei
jemandem der eben immer wieder diese
stereotypen hört und sieht das genau das
passiert das dann die person
wahrscheinlich sich an das gibt als was
sie sich geben würde wenn sie nicht
diesen diesen vorurteilen ständig
ausgesetzt werden huber wir haben jetzt
schon einige male auch gehört dass es
auch sehr auf die individuelle situation
darauf ankommt trotzdem noch die frage
gibt es bestimmte kombinationen und
religionszugehörigkeiten bei denen sie
sagen würden die chance dass es da gut
klappt ist größer also vielleicht
zwischen christentum judentum islam
aufgrund der nähe oder eben gerade
aufgrund der nähe eher heikel was wie
sehen sie das
also ich glaube also nach meiner
wahrnehmung der daten daher und auch der
literatur scheint mit die
religionszugehörigkeit selbst nicht so
wichtig zu sein sondern wichtig ist mein
anderes verhältnis von sozialer und
personal religiosität bei den partnern
wenn beide partner eine niedrige soziale
religiosität
dann fällt sehr viel zug weg wenn jetzt
zum ball aber nur ein partner eine
starke soziale realität hat und der
andere nicht
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit groß
dass sich der der diese nicht hat
annähert bis hin zur konversion und wenn
beide eine starke soziale religiosität
haben dann sind das wie zwei züge die
aufeinander zu rasen
und dann ist die frage wie stark ist die
personale seite und da ist eben meine
prognose je stärker die personale seite
ist umso leichter kann man sozusagen die
notbremse ziehen der sozialen züge und
versuchen gemeinsam einen weg zu tun ja
immer so als sei es die normalität dass
beide überhaupt religiös in irgendeiner
weise aber die tatsache die
wahrscheinlich heute viel gewichtiger
ist dass mindestens ein teil
konfessionslos vielleicht sogar
dezidiert atheistisch sich definiert
also gar nicht mehr religiös ist wie
beeinflusst dass das verhältnis zwischen
den partnern
ja ich meine dass das kann allerdings
auch neue probleme schaffen und neue
konflikte also wenn ein partner so zu
konfessionsfreie ist ja und gar nicht
religiös sozialisiert ist säkular ist
durch und durch und der andere partner
ist religiös dank dann muss man sich
dann gibt es vielleicht noch viel
größere verständigungsprobleme und wir
haben auch gesehen dass gibt diese
konstellation gewissermaßen am meisten
religiöse konflikte mehr hat wie halte
ich grundsätzlich mit der religion und
auf der anderen seite gibt es natürlich
mir haben einige paare wo die christlich
muslimische wo beide sozusagen nicht
mehr viel mit ihrer eigenen religiosität
mit ihrer eigenen religion am hut haben
und da haben sie sich dann sozusagen
auch gefunden
also ich hatte meine schlechten
erfahrungen als muslim mit dem islam
und ich hatte meine schlechten erfahrung
als christin mit der reformierten kirche
und dann sind wir glücklich mit dem was
wir beide uns sozusagen über die
institution gemeinsam ärgern und man hat
eine geteilte erfahrung
vielleicht doch auch noch die frage in
diesen die religiösen familien muss ja
viel über den kompromiss laufen sie
haben das auch schon erwähnt und ich
stelle mir doch vor dass dann sowohl auf
der einen seite die auf der anderen
seite auch eine art kulturverlust oder
religions- verlust stattfindet weil man
ja doch rituale festivitäten in
irgendeiner weise und die pflege der
gemeinschaft irgendwo ein bisschen
reduziert oder vielleicht sogar
abschleift verlieren damit am schluss
sogar beide seiten also ich denke das
kommt drauf an also für die kinder so
wie ich das beobachte könnte es eine
bereicherung sein wenn sie zum beispiel
das christliche und islamische leben
dürften ohne zwänge also so etwas
freiheit dass sie mal zu diesem fest
gehen dann zum anderen beides ist auf
gleicher ebene gleichwertig das problem
entsteht erst wenn sie merken da gibt es
ein kampf bei den eltern und es nicht
ausgesprochen
es wird so über sie ausgebeutet also
hast heute schon gebete geführt hast du
gefastet und das sind so
unterschiedlicher wert vermittlungen wo
sie dann nicht verstehen welche werte
sind denn jetzt richtig und dann haben
sie auch noch andere werte mit den peers
mit der schule viele herausforderungen
heute druck dazu zu gehören und dann
kommen noch diese zwei religionen dazu
aber ist es nicht auch ein stück weit
eine illusion zu glauben es könne sich
jemals auf augenhöhe bewegen weil die
mehrheitsgesellschaft eben doch auch
eine eine gewisse dominanz hab ich
glaube gerade in christlich muslimischen
familien erlebt man das ja praktisch
tagtäglich also das weihnachtsfest wird
ab ende oktober in den geschäften
angekündigt und alles wäre darauf
eingestimmt dass ganze kollektiv und für
die muslimischen feiertage muss man sich
speziell freinehmen eigentlich einen
sonnen davor leisten
man ist doch eigentlich nie auf
augenhöhe ich denke das ist ganz ein
wichtiger punkt
wir haben das so gemacht weil wir uns
war wichtig dass person meines mannes
zugang zu den islamischen
feierlichkeiten und ritualen hat dass
wir zum beispiel im ramadan wenn immer
möglich wirklich nach ägypten gereist
sind weil ramadan kann man in der
schweiz nicht erleben da muss man den
namen islamischen land sein und das ist
eine wunderbare zeit und wir haben das
ihm aber vollkommen frei gelassen ob er
mit fasten möchte oder nicht und er hat
sich dann aus eigenem willen dazu
entschieden dass er mit fasten rechte
und das dass wer immer das schon mal
erlebt hat den ramadan in einem
islamischen land dann fühlt man sich
dieser ganzen gesellschaft zugehörig
alle alle gehen durch die gleiche
situation der tag wird von den gebeten
strukturiert das ist sehr sehr viel
sozial was passiert das ist eine
wunderbare zeit und da wäre mal aber
jetzt er wieder im bereich der sozialen
religiosität und kaum ist man in der
schweiz verlangt man da die persönliche
religiöse das ist ja es ist schon ein
großer spagat das ist ein riesiger traum
aber ich denke ich denke den spagat
haben eine andere paare auch nur da ist
es vielleicht nicht religiös bedingt
sondern eine ein anderer spagat
natürlich ist es ein gewisses magath
kann ich da vielleicht auch etwas
anmerken also bei uns ist er also in der
schweiz oder in westeuropa ist sozusagen
die gesellschaftliche erwartung nicht zu
religiös sein sondern die wir sind
sozusagen säkular
ja und wenn man dann zu religiös ist
dann fällt man aus dem rahmen und das
dass es dann gewissermaßen die
problematik mit den mit denen auch
interreligiöse paare dann konfrontiert
sind
aber ich habe auch noch etwas zu
ergänzen
die toleranz üben wie sie gesagt haben
diese mehrheitsgesellschaft erlebe ich
jetzt bin ich die kinder und jugendliche
in der klinik beobachte sie haben wenig
toleranz also zb feiertag frei zu nehmen
da müssen sie ein joker tag nehmen weil
dieser feiertag ist jetzt in der schweiz
nicht schon festgehalten
ja ist kein typischer feiertag und da
kommt schon viele sich in frage stellen
praktisch dass die toleranz ist für die
für das ehe also für das paar oder für
die person die eben in der schweiz die
christine aber nicht für den
muslimischen mann der ehemann weil er
wäre in zum beispiel gerade im sudan zu
hause in seinem feiertagen und das kind
ist da und er lebt eben etwas
widersprüchlich ist weil die
gesellschaft eben andere feste hat wie
sie gesagt haben ist schon nicht so ganz
tolerant also wie dass das kind erlebt
also es ist schon nicht so ganz ohne
ohne herausforderungen und ohne
schwierigkeit und herr huber sie hat mir
im vorgespräch schon gesagt es sei
relativ schwierig überhaupt paare zu
finden die auskunftsfreudig sind und an
der studie teilnehmen und zwar nicht nur
an der online befragung sondern eben
dann auch in bei den qualitativen
interviews wir haben selbst zum teil die
gleichen erfahrungen gemacht auch auf
der redaktion ist es schwierig leute in
die öffentlichkeit sozusagen zu bringen
mit diesen herausforderungen die wird
gerade besprechen sind das die einzigen
gründe warum sie denken dass hart star
oder wie genau begründen sie das also
ich kann natürlich nicht in die herzen
der menschen schauen aber ich vermute
dass das sie eben doch eine ganze menge
diskriminierungserfahrungen haben wegen
dieser interessen erschöpfen und deshalb
ist das für sie ein heißes eisen dass
sie eher ruhen lassen
und da nicht darüber offiziell sprechen
möchten sie verorten dass er beiden
diskriminierungserfahrungen sie haben in
ihrer studie aber auch festgestellt dass
der große teil der paare die
teilgenommen hat sehr zufrieden sind
müsste man dann nicht auch davon
ausgehen dass vielleicht sich auch nur
die bei ihnen melden und mitmachen die
eine gewisse lockerheit haben einerseits
aber die vielleicht auch tatsächlich
weniger schwierigkeit haben wogegen die
wo die herausforderungen groß sind
vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt noch
schlafende hunde wecken wollen und sich
deshalb auch mich über diese themen mit
anderen austauschen wollen
also ich denke muss man zwei punkte
auseinander halten
erst einmal ist das ergebnis
interreligiöse paare sind sehr zufrieden
sie sind im prinzip genauso
zufrieden wird der religiös homogene
partei das heißt sie sind ganz normale
paare das war ja dieses eine eines
unserer hauptergebnisse jetzt das andere
sind die diskriminierungserfahrungen und
dann ja die die wird die die
bereitschaft sozusagen darüber zu reden
ja und also kommunikation scheint ja
überhaupt ein knackpunkt zu sein sie
führen das auf als eines der ganz der
der erstgenannten problemfeld also wenn
wir fragen was sind denn eigentlich die
themen bei denen die die religiösen
paare ins stocken kommen dann ist es
kommunikation ist offenbar schwierig
genau also da da zeigt sich ein
unterschied also nicht mehr
zufriedenheit aber die frage wo treten
konflikte auf in welchen bereichen und
da ist es zum beispiel so religiöse
konflikte die sind bei interreligiösen
pan viel häufiger auf als bei homogenen
religiösen das ist versteht man auch
ganz einfach ja ich glaube bei dem regus
homogen ist es der vorletzte platz der
fünfundzwanzigste platz von 26 während
der andere ist es der achte platz ja
aber auch nur der achte und dann
zweitens auch konflikte mit
schwiegereltern ja die dann ja sozusagen
die andere religion noch mal von dritter
seite her profitieren
und die stehen dort an sechster stelle
und bei den homogenen an 16 tagen aber
interessant ist was sozusagen an erster
stelle genannt wird und das sind ist bei
dem die religiösen bahn an erster stelle
kommunikation und an zweiter stelle
regulierung von nähe und distanz
und da vermutlich aber das hängt weniger
mit der unterschiedlichen religionen
sondern mit den unterschiedlichen
kulturen zusammen das heißt welchen stil
habe ich zu kommunizieren und wie wird
nähe und distanz in einer partnerschaft
gelebt also sind diese beiden aspekte
sogar miteinander verknüpft die
kommunikation und die frage nach nähe
und distanz ja das ist der erste und
zweite stelle und das ist eben
interessant bei den
mono religiösen pan dort steht an erster
stelle konsumverhalten was kaufe ich ein
und an zweiter stelle 6 steht sexualität
ja und das kommt bei dem interreligiösen
erst sehr viel später und aber wie schon
gesagt ich vermute das hängt mit dem bbi
kulturellen kontext zusammen und nicht
mit der religiosität dass sich also
absolut zu unterstreichen ich denke
frauen und männer kommunizieren schon
mal anders
unabhängig davon welche religion zu
spielern und dann kommen die
unterschiede aus den kulturen also ich
hab das immer wieder auch gesehen jetzt
im arabischen kontext das oft gewisse
dinge auch nicht direkt angesprochen
werden sondern sie werden umschrieben
märz hatte genau und das ist nicht immer
ganz einfach dann als europäer zu
verstehen wohin geht eigentlich die
reise und das ist sehr sehr interessant
also ich denke kommunikation und ebenso
banal es sich anhört es ist oftmals
schon nur die gemeinsame sprache zu
haben eine sprache in der sich beide
partner wohlfühlen wo sie auf augenhöhe
miteinander sprechen also deshalb habe
ich auch gesagt sie haben englisch
gewählt die heiklen diskussion wenn
beide in einer fremdsprache diskutieren
dann sind auch beide gleichermaßen
benachteiligt sozusagen und sonst kann
dann die dominanz wieder eine eine große
rolle spielen oder am ende dann doch
etwas ergänzt damit zu dem stichwort
kommunikation also aus der allgemeinen
paare forschung und und beziehungs
forschung wissen wir dass kommunikation
einer der wichtigsten faktoren ist der
zum gelingen einer partnerschaft führt
also solange man miteinander redet ist
es gut und wenn man eben gerade so aus
unterschiedlichen kulturen und
unterschiedlichen religionen kommt dann
ist man sozusagen gezwungen mehr
miteinander zu reden und hat damit die
chance auch mehr kommunikative
kompetenzen auszubilden also das muss
man das ist sozusagen ein pluspunkt von
internet ein plus das interreligiöse
paare haben und das
hat sich auch in vielen qualitativen
studien bestätigt die zeigen
interreligiöse paare lernen tiefer
miteinander zu kommunizieren weil es
eben die herausforderung größer ist
heißt das auch dass die religiöse paare
sich darauf einstellen müssen dass das
thema an sich nie erledigt ist dass das
immer wieder phasen war ist also
praktisch täglich immer wieder aufkommt
und dass die themen nie ausgehen also in
unsere gesellschaft würde ich dem
zustimme dann aber den gesellschaften wo
ich erklärten und patientenbetreuung zum
beispiel afghanistan oder zusammen da
gibt es gar keine diskussion da ist es
klar
so wird das gelebt und so ist man
sozialisiert und das ist auch für den
kindern leichter gewesen sie mussten
nicht darüber nachdenken so habe ich
mich zu verhalten als mädchen so habe
ich nicht zu halten als junge und die
mehrheitsgesellschaft dort tickt dann ja
auch dann ebenso also islamisch zum
beispiel aber hier in dieser
gesellschaft wo wir hier sind wiederum
ist es anders da muss man sehr viel
hinterfragen muss ich so leben kann ich
mich so anziehen also die jugendlich
haben viele herausforderungen weil die
gesellschaft ja individualistische ist
und da suchen sie dann einen anderen
halt also es hat was mit der
gesellschaftsform zu tun weil die
sozialisation sich eben immer wieder
ändert wir sehen schon fast am ende ein
thema das mich zum schluss noch
interessiert sondern ein ausdruck blick
in die in die zukunft herr huber sie
haben über die religiöse paare auch
schon gesagt dass sein labor wo ein
friedliches interreligiöses
zusammenleben aus geprobt wird und damit
auch experimentiert wird welche oder was
tun wir denn als gesellschaft und diese
ressourcen die bei diesen experimenten
und bei diesem laborieren entstehen dass
diese ressourcen dann in die gesamte
gesellschaft fließen
raus aus dem labor der tu mir eben noch
viel zu wenig und das war auch ein
weiteres motiv für diese studie
und das wäre auch vom schweizer
nationalfonds geld beantragt haben
bekommen was wir sagen wir wollen
sozusagen das wissen die praktischen
erfahrungen die kompetenzen der
interreligiösen bahre anzapfen
und in die gesellschaft vermitteln und
sozusagen diese studie und dann
natürlich nicht die studie allein
sondern wenn wir dann publizieren dazu
und zwar nicht nur wissenschaftlich
sondern auch allgemein verständlichen
zeitungen und dann natürlich auch für
beratungsstellen
da hoffen wir dass das es impulse gibt
für ein wird dass weitere interreligiöse
gespräch frau bock sie arbeiten ja im
bereich personalrekrutierung und ich
schätze mal sie haben ihre
interkulturellen und interreligiösen
kompetenzen die sie erlangt haben jetzt
vermehrt auch in ihre arbeit einbringen
können absolut ich führe ein sehr
internationales interreligiöses team und
da hilft mir das natürlich jeden tag
weil ich habe eher säkulare leute meinem
team ich habe sehr gläubige leute in
meinem team sein dass katholiken sein
dass muslime sein dass leute die
vielleicht religion für für die religion
kein so großes thema ist die menschen
kommen aus ganz unterschiedlichen
herkunftsländern
und da hilft mir dass es hilft mir aber
auch regeln aufzustellen wie wir
miteinander umgehen sodass dass jeder
auch sich selber sein darf weil das ist
ja oftmals auch das problem sich selber
sein denn in einem team
ich glaube an internationale
interkulturelle teams die sind das sind
denkfabriken das sind kreative orte aber
nur dann wenn sich die leute wohlfühlen
da ein sobald sie sich anpassen müssen
irgendjemanden oder diskriminiert sich
fühlen dann dann geht das genau das
gegenteil aber in unserem team ist das
sehr sehr wichtig und also konkret
werden in ihrem team termin
unterschiedliche feiertage begangen
gültig hinter feiertage muslimische
feiertage gibt es einen gebetsraum für
alle oder also dass das gibt es in der
form nicht vor allem weil wir auch alle
remote arbeiten also jetzt oder so aber
auch da aber auch ansonsten auch schon
vor corinna war das sehr sehr stark der
fall
aber ich habe natürlich eine toleranz
dafür dass leute zb gläubige muslime im
ramadan ihre arbeitszeiten anpassen
sodass es besser passt für und zieht
damit auch fassen können dass sie im zur
moschee gehen können an einem freitag
dass das überhaupt gar kein problem ist
dass wir verschiedene themen
es gibt einfach verschiedene sprüche
witze die einfach nicht toleriert werden
in diesem team zu der die die unterbinde
ich von anfang an und das finde ich ganz
ganz wichtig weil das ist dann auch
meine aufgabe mich dann schützend vor
andere zu stellen
aber das funktioniert sehr sehr gut und
ich und ich spüre wie viel wie viel
energie und wie viel kreativität daraus
entsteht die wir brauchen in unserem
täglichen in unserer täglichen arbeit
frau aus tv wenn sie ein oder zwei sätze
noch zu der frage sagen könnten wie
sehen sie dass die ressourcen die da
sind in oder aus pirelli ösen familien
wie die besser noch in die gesellschaft
hinein fließen können also kinder sind
ja schulpflichtig in der schule im
kindergarten in der krippe wo die kinder
auch immer sind dass dort fachpersonen
sozusagen offenheit entwickeln wie die
kinder dass sie sich weiterbilden und
dass sie die kinder tragen können aber
auch die sozusagen die kinder die damit
gar keine berührung haben also die
inländer praktisch auch die aufgeklärt
werden über über ressourcen dieser
kinder auch vielleicht über die dass sie
anders kleiden dass das vorteil abgebaut
werden und stereotypen
ich finde gerade schule ist ein
wichtiger ein wichtiger ort wo kultur
und religion sozusagen anders
aufgegriffen werden kann also das würde
dann wiederum für die lehrstelle für die
weitere entwicklung dieser jugendlichen
ganz viel bieten das dem wir gerne als
schlusswort mit ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen allen dass sie am gespräch
teilgenommen haben ihn ganz besonders
dass ihr auch viel aus ihrem
persönlichen leben berichtet haben
herzlichen dank eingeschrieben nächste
woche zeigen wir ihnen einen
dokumentarfilm über den warschauer
stadtteil mutter noch auf den trümmern
des einstigen warschauer ghettos gibt
auch sind die geister der vergangenheit
dort heute noch spürbar
und jetzt gleich trifft barbara bleisch
den psychoanalytiker und satiriker peter
schneider zum gespräch bleiben sie dran
und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]